the pennzoil 400 is sunday in the las
vegas motor speedway who is sponsoring
this next segment lets you feel like a
real driver with their nascar experience
jc visited the track for test run
as we get ready for race day we're
taking you inside the nascar racing
experience but before we hit the track
we gotta hit the classroom
todd my man
what's going on buddy good to see you
again man i'm ready to hit the track
today i'm excited about this but tell me
more about the experience people walk in
they check in what do we do here yeah so
this is our media center here what we're
going to do is we're going to come in
and sign our track waiver
we're going to give you a lanyard it's
got an sd card in it for a video if you
want to purchase it uh then once you uh
are checked in here you're going to walk
over here and basically i'm going to put
you in a fire suit um and then from
there we're going to go right into the
classroom this is where the teaching is
this is it where it happens this is it
right here so this is our our uh
instructor classroom in here you're
going to go through a 25-minute video uh
and then from here you're going to go
out to the racetrack where you're going
to have a second part of the classroom
we call it our pit road speech
uh once we have the pit road speech then
we get you in the race car now there's
two options too you can drive the car
itself well that's what we're doing
today i'm doing the ride-along i want
you the master of the track to take me
around sure no worries let's go you're
ready for a
i ride-along but where do you guys keep
the cars
holy smokes this is incredible
isn't this amazing in here yeah what do
we got here these are actual race cars
that we get from the teams back uh on
the east coast all right um we put our
own engine in it we put a couple of
seats and a dash and we basically call
it a day we don't do much to these cars
these cars are actually
you know that's right that's right but
this is the one
that you really should be interested in
this is the one that we're going to
drive into this uh joey logano joey
legano
yeah yeah with the pencil 400 coming i
think this should be the car
[Music]
go ahead and put your left leg over all
right then you're right
go ahead and slide down into the foot
compartment there
help you with your helmet
there you go good job i do have a
question this is the steering wheel you
just attached it have you ever been
driving the thing popped out never okay
because what i do is i do uh i test the
steering wheel and pull on it just to
make sure and that's standard nascar
steering this is standard yeah you'll
always see the guys so it's a quick
release it's called okay so basically
what you're going to do is reach through
the steering wheel pull back on it and
then put it on the steering
column and then you're always going to
test it to pull it back perfect here we
go let's do it time
so
[Music]
[Music]
wow that's how it's done that's how you
go 165 miles an hour we did 165 165
right there brother
that is the nascar experience thank you
guys hey thank you jc great to have you
out here man i'm ready for the race
let's do it let's go